King good evening greetings I'm Ben
prosky director of events at the
Graduate School of Architecture thank
you so much for coming I could stand up
here and tell you a long story about how
this evening came about so I'm gonna
have to be cut off if I start doing that
but this is exciting we're in the middle
of a big project with the School of the
Arts and this evening is an extension of
it several years ago I guess we got a
grant with the School of the Arts to
start working together and Columbia as
most of you know is under under galia
salomon often liam gillick guidance is
going to design a summer pavilion and
with students from the school the arts
and the school of architecture and this
is really a first because if anyone has
tried to even build a matchstick house
on the campus here you'll it'll it'll
get shut down so um I shouldn't say that
too much to do still have some talks to
do but but it will be done in time for
commencement and so we're so happy that
you're all here because we now want to
look towards some really wonderful
people who have done really creative
work with temporary structures and
that's you're going to hear from tonight
so I will pass it to galia who will
introduce the speakers
hello I'm going to introduce the
speakers and the beat of the reason
behind what why we want to do a pavilion
there's two definitions there's two
etymological traces to the war pavilion
one according to be at risk alumina
comes from the word Papillon meaning
butterfly in French and so the idea was
that these lightweight structures appear
in the summer in gardens and and so the
pavilion in that way is associated with
a tent then there is the other a
potential etymological definition of
pavilion are coming from a puppy Leonen
a Latin word and that word was refers to
when a Roman warrior would go into an
unknown territory they would keep
standards the map in beyond vido a tent
and I actually really like the
definition of pavilion because i think
it implies as you move into an unknown
territory you need to have a home you
need to have a place where you keep your
bearings you keep your maps and also the
idea that when something when you
confront a new challenge and you have to
settle the score the place where peace
agreements where sign was below the
pavilion so if if if it's your turn to
go to somebody's pavilion it's because
you are conceding up to that person
power and if diaper if you go to
somebody else's pavilion you will be
giving up so the idea that piece trivets
and and words were settled under
tends to its appealing to me and related
to that there was this Pavilion in 1958
le corbusier are unseen hockey's unbury
see ya thank you ah it's it's great it's
great and I recommend that you see it
but I am I just want to kiss you with
this and you can see it later and so in
1958 le corbusier parece and sanaa keys
I built for the Philips company a Dutch
company that does electronics a pavilion
this was after World War two it was the
first international exhibition and the
idea was to gather all the arts under
one roof that's the building the
building once it was a concrete shell
building that's like most pavilions they
exist for a very short time and then
they disappear forever there's not this
doesn't exist anymore there's no
Mobile's of it and and so they
constructed a poem electronic unelected
electronic poem and that had colors and
music and this is a small piece from
that pavilion that as I present the
speakers I would like you two to see the
idea was to no show no showcase within
the pavilion the technology of
per se not as an object but to
demonstrate what technology could do to
unite the different arts and so my the
reason why I'm interested in these
tonight is because I think that we could
update this idea we could do a very much
more modest construction than these
probably and think about the new
challenges that are that the arts can
demonstrate and proceed I'm make an
effort to present an idea together so
the I'm very happy to be teaching with
liam gillick it's a picture it's a
challenge to teach two different sets of
other students art students and
architecture students they have
different attitudes you know we are just
few buildings apart but there are many
different attitudes towards a
construction towards the way we view
problems the way we position ourselves
critically to our surroundings so it's a
it's a challenging combination and I
hope we'll get to build something
together and so Liam Didache graduated
from cosmic College in 1987 in 1980
night he mounted his first solo gallery
exhibition 84 diagrams in Gong Gong
together with Damien hurt sorry Lucas
Angela gulag and hearing Henry bond he's
considered one of the earliest members
of the Y bas young British artist who
dominated thinkin since then
is in 2002 gillick was nominated for the
tournament prize in 2009 oolitic
represented germany in the venice
biennale in october 1 2010 in an open
letter to the british government he
co-signed it with 27 previous Turner
Prize nominees and 19 winners unopposed
all cuts to public funding for the Arts
he believes one of the Graduate
committee members of the Center for
curatorial studies in contemporary art
and culture at Bard College I give you
liam gillick all right good evening
there should be a PowerPoint up there
somewhere just it was getting good I'd
like to just acknowledge the the
generosity of the architect department
at tolerating this collaboration and I'm
just going to do a very short
presentation but just to point out one
or two structural things that in the
last 20 years primarily my experience of
the interchange between architecture and
art or some discussion about the
possibilities of the belt world has
tended to assume that the best structure
to do that within is some kind of
notionally open framework that usually
is something that we could recognize
within a contemporary art context and
what's very important for this kind of
collaboration is that we're really
taking the lead from the way the
architecture department is structured on
the way this this attempt to build this
temporary building is is geared is
towards doing something within the
context of architecture so that makes an
enormous
difference to the the the the the stakes
become different they don't necessarily
become higher they just become of a
different order that all of the usual
free-flowing talks about the idea of
open discourse or the architecture of
the possible law or the kind of micro
utopias that have been proposed over the
last 20 years in the art context are all
troubled and agitated and disturbed by
the fact that we have a concrete literal
thing to have to achieve now what I'm
going to do quickly is do two things one
is to show you images that are just
evidence that I'll try and show as a
sort of backdrop that our images of
things I've been involved with to show
the extent to which in and they span a
20-year period sure the extent to which
some forms of art have been dealing with
this idea of the temporary structure or
the pavilion as it were as a ongoing
process but at the same time one of the
things that I think is important to talk
about is that that some people will
assume that the common areas of this
exercise are to do with what gets built
to do with the common interest in form
whereas in fact the hardest thing to
really drag out our issues around use
and people and the relationship between
people and people and people and objects
and so in that light I want to do a very
short well it was short when I did it
earlier sure reading from the work of an
artist a French artist called Philippe
Peraino who in 1996 presented an event
in dijon called snow dancing now the
book that was the artwork didn't really
describe much of a building didn't
really describe much of a structure but
it did describe a kind of event and by
doing this I just want to sort of set
the scene for the evening and give us
keeping our minds this idea of people
and users and some kind of function okay
and I'm going to try and change the
at the same time okay we must now
describe we must now describe the people
attending the event they are eclectic
yet an eclecticism that has become the
standard in other words diversity is
normal as with the building itself there
is no dominant style for the people who
happen to be here if you start try and
define a dress code for them everything
collapses people addressed in a way that
indicates effort has been made but
without intending to produce real
meaning details are not discussed but
accepted as long as they create
diversity everyone's appearance is
precise a degree of sophistication is
visible in a clear visual language
capable of being read by everyone baggy
shapeless faded jeans that make people
that clear blurred and ill-defined a
popular this corresponds to a way of
seeing the world like a soft-focus
fashion spread some people are wearing
eyeglasses but not to correct their
vision but to blur it slightly to mimic
a popular form of fashion advertising
it's pleasurable to see the world
slightly out of focus it helps one comes
to terms with marketing think about
washing detergent where two items of
clothing are washed in different
detergents one remains clear and
colorful the other is left faded and
ill-defined in the same way at the event
some people are faded and other people
addressed in a rather rigid way wearing
stiff clothing it's almost as if their
jackets are too exacting for them an
effect that you get when you put on new
clothing for the first time some people
like their jackets or trousers to be
always new expensive looking and
slightly uncomfortable clothes designed
by famous fashion designers or
convincing fakes other people enjoy the
padding found in cheap anoraks they
deliberately tear these coats to reveal
the thick white cotton interior everyone
is the embodiment of a dress code
although there are many different styles
of clothing it's clear that people have
thought hard about the way they should
look imagine a dinner attended by people
from several different countries they
all might agree to speak a common
language in order to be understood or
they might decide to talk in a mix of
languages
you can participate you don't have to be
like anyone else you are supposed to be
at the same time similar and dissimilar
to everyone else identical and different
is a slogan that you can see in many
rooms people want to be like other
people while at the same time
maintaining a strong identity you can
see people with a hairstyle that's long
at the back but short neatly cut at the
sides on top soccer players used to have
this look it's a haircut that reveals
that has been carefully considered this
haircut reveals identification with the
working classes the people who do not
have energy to create a hairstyle wear
wigs that don't require so much effort
at the party there is a place to buy
wigs so people can change their look at
any moment some people are wearing big
heavy engineers boots while others might
be wearing the kind of footwear that you
might put on to go scuba diving each
type of footwear completely covers the
foot and ankle you can visit a shoemaker
at the party the shoemaker will cut
revolutionary slogans in the soles of
your shoes people leave tracks in the
dirt and dust on the floor reminiscent
of the first footprints on the moon
people can get keys cut at the same time
the locksmith generally cuts the same
key over and over again by the end of
the party he may have made 500 copies of
the key that opens all the doors the
place belongs to the community so if you
lock a door anyone can open it there are
other places where you can put together
a look people pick out different items
to compose an outfit the shopkeepers
ignore you some people like dayglo
clothes like a kind of luminous vests
worn by rail workers safety clothing
like in Formula One people are covered
in logos inevitably some people at the
event look as if they are sponsored not
the building with colour schemes
derivative of various labels most of the
participants are locals even the people
coming from a long distance look like
they're locals people dance a lot maybe
this defines their level of commitment
others just drink there are no children
they stay outside and
and cars or buses looked after by an old
man everyone seems to spend the same
amount of money wealth is not revealed
by people spending habits maybe this is
because everything here is free however
there is a difference in the way people
speak it does not necessarily betray
class and anyway a lot of people alter
their accent her modernization is helped
by the fact that people are wearing so
many layers of clothes that it's hard to
tell if they're beautiful or ugly some
might say everyone is perfect the
general impression is that people are
handsome charming and sexy but maybe too
fat too thin too tall or too short a lot
of discussions take place but nothing of
any great significance is said some of
the people are really engaged almost as
if they're being paid to have a good
time this is not dissimilar to Euro
Disney some people at the murder of the
event at our event you don't know
exactly who animates who there are also
passive groups who take observer status
they don't react they read a lot talk a
great deal and sometimes exchange
pictures taken during the event in the
same way that children make collections
of things it is not clear what they say
to each other mumbling a bit
conversations are difficult to overhear
passive people stick together people at
the event enjoy playing games games
remind people of their constant
interaction in existence for them play
allows access to power these are not
ordinary games for abstract ones where
rules can always change it's hard
controller situation where rules change
constantly dominant power structures in
society like government bureaucracy are
not successful games because they do not
understand the potential of play the
entire world is the domain where the
creative impulse of the party can be
deployed think about the resold shoes
then you can start to imagine that the
whole community is linked together by
playful but not imposed ideals this is
the key to the revolutionary impulse of
this promotional event
thank you
is the founding partner of c2 studio
born in England to Turkish parents he
came to the u.s. at age three and grew
up in New Jersey he attended the Cooper
Union School of Architecture graduating
in 2005 at which point he started the
firm with four other classmates he has
previously taught at the other valid
architecture department at Pratt
Institute thank you come here and thank
you to columbia university quite an
honor to be invited to present here so
i'll be presenting three pavilions today
which were part of a series that we call
the solar pavilions they're quite small
scale and temporary works they were only
up for about a few days at a time the
first one we built in 2006 the solar
pavilion one second one in 2007 and the
third one in 2008 the original event
that they were made for or the original
clients is this organization called
solar one which is a environmental
nonprofit organization and they hold
this event every summer called city soul
which is basically this three day long
street festival that takes place in this
park it's a it's kind of there's music
they have band performing they have food
and drinks and various art and
informational exhibits and so in 2006
they invited us to make something for
this event and we we basically through
this organization we got a donation
of a large amount of cardboard tubes so
we took this opportunity to build a
pavilion an actual usable space within
this area so this was about a 2,000 or
about 1,000 square foot roof structure
that provided shade and there were
seating areas within this roof there was
a ticket booth food and drink stands and
various exhibits were were mounted in
different areas under this roof so the
first year turned out fairly
successfully so they invited us back the
following year which had a much larger
turnout there were quite a number of
popular bands performing and so this was
the one covered area that people could
go under to watch the performances and
then the third year again the same event
occurred and one of the days of this
festival they they organized a series of
presentations and a panel discussion
which was held and we made this kind of
auditory in like area within part of the
pavilion to have these presentations so
this this event was three days long so
you know we didn't want to just make
something that would only live for this
three day long event so we really had in
mind that the desire to create a
traveling pavilion so the this main
theme was deployability especially in
the second and third iterations of this
project so part of this was mobility
being able to transport the pavilion
quickly and easily flat packing it and
then you know really have this thing
have multiple lives so what you see here
is the third pavilion which in its
largest manifestation was about 3,000
square feet and it's all flat packed
into the
one 24 foot truck on its way to one of
the events and the other aspect of this
idea of deployability was a
reconfigurable ax t so we didn't want to
just move it from place to place but the
real idea was can we build it
differently each time so depending on
the needs of each venue and the site
conditions and how the people might flow
through the space we want it to really
be able to transform this structure so
just to go through these four right here
are all solar pavilion two so we
basically made these diagrams of each of
the four manifestations of it which I'll
just show you in some more detail so
this was the first one at city hall with
the bar in the middle and then various
other programs and then the second
manifestation was at the dumbo art
festival where the pavilion took on is
very linear form I'm it was sort of
functioned like a shaded arcade along
this pathway that led from the street to
the left to the Brooklyn Bridge Park
over to the right so it was this like
entry passage leading to the park where
there was a series of art installations
and then a few months after that we put
everything back on the truck and drove
it down to Miami for the art fair and
the pavilion we built it there in front
of the scope art fair as a sort of entry
portico so the fair itself was held in
this white tent behind the structure and
our pavilion served as a filter to guide
the visitors into that space there was
three passages and this like tunnel
space to the right which was for the
general public
one to the left for the VIP and then
there was a central passage that was the
exit for out of the tent and then
finally we had the pavilion inn in a
container for a year and we took it out
one last time a year later to take you
to the all points west music festival in
Liberty State Park New Jersey and here
it was kind of this rest pavilion it was
a bit in a in a large field away from
the two main music venues I mean we made
it to have these two views toward the
two stages and then a third year looking
out into into the Hudson River
waterfront so one thing to mention with
these diagrams these were all produced
after the event they were sort of like a
way to document what had developed
during the installation prior to
arriving at a site we would we never
really defined what the form would be
the project was really about developing
certain assembly logics in each of the
three pavilions there's certain rule
sets that we develop for how parts go
together so the way that what these
drawings are serving to show is this
notation of different types of line
correspond to different hierarchy of
members and each one having different
characteristics that determine where in
the structure they go so when we derive
on a site we'd really you know we get
there with a group of people a truck
full of parts and we kind of quickly
sketch out what we might want to do with
the structure there have some idea about
how people would interact with it and
you know whether there were other
functions that the pavilion would serve
so we'd have this kind of really quick
sketch of of some sort of direction and
then we basically begin this
this participatory event of the
installation and in many cases we'd have
a different group of volunteers
assisting us with this so we'd really
just teach them those those basic
assembly rules and then this sort of
freeform growth process would proceed
where we're really just guiding guiding
this development you know changing it
modifying it making it wider or narrower
adding a passage here there it was
really this like fluid freeform kind of
construction so no one part really has
any position it's it's you know it's
much more of this almost like this
bottom-up paradigm of growth where we're
not really following a plan that's
predefined but it's more of like this
open-ended process that could
potentially continue endlessly
so this is the first manifestation of
pavilion 3 at the city soul festival and
some images of it complete the basic
system here is essentially these lattice
like plywood strips that are woven in a
certain pattern and they can pack they
can flat pack and they're pinned
together with these aluminum connectors
and then on-site with these other linear
struts that are basically expanded out
so they can travel flat and then they
just get pulled out to create volume and
then there's a secondary system of vinyl
membranes that provided that were
suspended beneath the plywood armature
producing shade now this idea of a
system of assembly that's driving the
form is was really defined through an
articulation of the details we'd have
some basic idea about a structural a
structural system that we'd basically
resolve it in through really defining
how the connections would work we would
develop the degree of flexibility and
while also achieving a structural
strength that would be required so
basically the on the this is showing the
second pavilion and the basic system
here on the bottom right is a consists
of these series of plywood strips that
have an interlocking edge detail and
they basically notch into each other and
are held together with zip ties and if
you remove certain key joints the this
whole unit can basically collapse into a
flat bundle so likewise similar to the
pavilion three
Travel flat and then you expand it out
put these key connections back in and
add additional members and it becomes a
stable form and so once we had this
basic idea we would proceed through kind
of evolving this joint which both gave
us a flexibility and structural strength
and we it was really we were trying to
fine-tune this the geometry of this so
that it you know it would serve our
needs and they have this um it became
this zigzagging form which is really a
result of certain practical constraints
of manufacturing so it's basically a
single cut is producing two sides of two
parts and essentially there was no waste
you know every part of the sheet that's
left over has this joint and it is
capable of connecting anywhere in the
structure
so here's just a the installation
sequence in Miami it would basically
take one day to put up a majority of the
structure and then a second day when
basic with any additional members that
are put in serve to further stiffen this
structure so it kind of like was was
made itself rigid over time as we
installed more pieces and then here in
the second day we're adding the this
secondary system to provide shade which
in this case where these plastic semi
flexible plastic panels
and so these these flexible panels also
were malleable enough that they could
kind of follow the geometry of the
resulting in plywood structure so one of
the one of the ways that we're really
working at this and central to our
practice in general is through building
we have a shop in Brooklyn adjacent to
our office and all of these pavilions
develop through building at a full scale
and making mock-ups and testing them to
see if we could get the get the
flexibility and deployability that we
were looking for and so we basically
build at a you know from smaller
mock-ups up to larger and larger ones
we'd get temporary spaces in our
building do do fairly rigorous
structural analyses and then take it out
to an empty lot to do run throughs
outside tested see how it handled the
wind and the rain and I'll just finish
with this last video showing the the
production of the third pavilion
basically all the various machinery and
things that we did during its during its
development and we built all of these
ourselves and I mean that really for
project like this it was only really
possible for us to do it ourselves I
mean because we are really besides being
low budget projects we were working with
this idea of reconfigure ability and you
know working without drawings so it was
really only possible that we had the
means to go and just build these and
though they're very temporary very
short-term small projects they did allow
us to experiment at
sexual level you know and not having to
worry about issues like codes and you
know because their fur for very small
events there was never really issues
that they had to be applying to fire
codes or or other liabilities so it'll
be interesting you know these were
projects we started within one year of
coming out of school so it'll be
interesting to see how certain ideas
like these can can still become present
in our future work as you know in more
permanent pavilions and other projects
these were we made a series of lights
out of crushed glass and that's what I
what these are showing
thank you so the good thing of being in
your forties is that you can say I no
chance frame flow from 17 18 years ago
and and so that is the case with a last
two people in the panel Charles
graduated from Columbia 1994 the same
year that I did um he's a practicing
architect a base in New York City Renfro
was associate an associate Alice Smith
Miller Hawking son before joining Diller
Scofidio in 1997 he has served as
project leader on brasserie eyebeam
divine master plan with Alma blur the
Boston Institute of Contemporary Art
freeze until firm flow has serve as the
same principle for the redesign and
expansion of the scholia school alice
tully hall public spaces a Lincoln
Center for the Performing Arts the High
Line and the Museum of the image and
sound in Rio de Janeiro among other
projects Renfro is a graduate of rice
university and false a master degree
from visa and is teaching i'll pass on
currently i'll give you a child
hey there it's great to be back I don't
get up here very often it's not bad to
commute actually the one side so maybe
I'll try it to make it i think i'm doing
six events this semester up here
something crazy but anyway it's great to
be back and I'm going to just it's going
to be really short and so I'm just going
to talk about one project that we're
working on I mean you you might know
that we've you know we've done our fair
share of temporary structures in them in
around the world and one in particular
you might know is called a blur building
was built in 2002 was made of like water
from like neuchtel it lasted for six
months and then it was imploded despite
the fact that it was only four columns
of steel so but that I mean speaks to
the temporary nature of these things the
pavilion that i'm going to show today is
for the hirshhorn museum in washington
DC right on the mall it is temporary it
is a permanent temporary pavilion or a
temporary permanent pavilion IE can
figure out what that what it is but it's
built to be to occupy it same site over
and over i'll talk more about that as i
go through the slides there's the mall
how do i do this is a pc
oh okay you know max don't have
keyboards any night just get everything
anyway it's on the south side of the
mall Gordon bunch at building iconic
structure it it's oh good there you know
it's a it's a classical modernism in
that it mirrors a park that it exists
pre-existed the hirshhorn across the
mall it's part of the Smithsonian of
course means it's a free a free museum
which is pretty cool it's it's a
terribly you know this is when the
hirshhorn was made was actually
originally a plan to be off-center the
whole was going to be asymmetrically
positioned in in the museum which is
kind of interesting and now it's
actually smack in middle these are some
of the original drawings but it's a pure
form it's inviolable and so when the
director Richard coachella came to us
and said we need you guys to help us
think about how to make a an event space
and a cafe and lobby and you know all
the things that museums need in their
lives to stay financially secure you
know we looked at the museum and we're
faced with that dilemma a closed donut
of a building it doesn't lend itself to
permanent addition and yet it has plenty
of space in the in the hole the donut
there's not even there's not even really
a lobby so to speak much less a place
for events or bar mitzvahs or weddings
or things that museums make their money
doing these things now it's it's also
Smithsonian which means it sort of
serves a sort of higher or its its rule
by a higher decision-making body which
is is you know
States government which makes it harder
to get things approved and also since
it's on the mall and the mall has very
strict building codes and it's difficult
to to do anything there we know from
having been one of the competitors for
national african american museum and one
well the people whose competitions
anyway so we have a place in our office
that's like I call it you know the tunes
I call the cemetery and it's made of
tombstones it's all our boards that
we've submitted for competitions that
have all been lost and there are
probably about 200 boards there and we
just thumb through them and this was one
of it was very sad I think right um what
was clever shush okay nevermind we've
been doing better now but um anyway uh
so Richard kachellek sort of actually
thought that maybe there would be a way
to make something temporary and we
agreed and we identified this the
courtyard of course as being the
opportunity and also the exposed Plaza
that's protected from weather underneath
the rings of the donut and and of course
we started thinking about the inflate
structure it's a pretty pretty most
pretty logical solution have been
there's been a lot of work done and
inflate structures including amazed work
you know there's a lot of really great
developments in recent years and a lot
of a lot but several companies around
the world that are really at the
forefront of pushing the envelope so to
speak in this forum so anyway we just
started thinking about the whole and you
know what you can do with the whole and
you know so you can have fun with holes
especially
yeah and so the concept I mean it's
really simple that we make a soft
structure that inflates and provides new
space for the museum and so that's
that's it and then and it does that and
in this this will happen twice a year
for one month every year in the fall and
spring and they'll have a series of
events symposia that is new cafe etc I'm
just going to sort of go through the
stuff it means pretty obvious what it is
a little cafe it's sort of like a
herniated disc you know it sort of oozes
out from underneath the the form of the
donut and and it provides a sort of
inside outside experience on the ground
floor which there isn't such a thing at
the Museum yet this is looking at it I
think this is from the mall but I always
get confused no actually this is from
from the from the street so it will
provide any profile was so brilliant
about the idea that Richard came up with
which was to use the hole in some way is
we were able to sort of get around all
of the legislative and code and zonnique
netcode but zoning issues around working
in the mall or at least most of them
they've been much more lenient so the
pavilion as a closet as a way to not
make people unsafe but as a way to
expand the potential of space making is
a really interesting concept this this
pavilion it's it's a low-pressure
inflate which means that it's it's it's
almost a room fan that keeps it up not
much more than that it is air
conditioned and heated so it really is
internal space it's got a high degree of
soundproofing actually and it allows us
to to present theater theatrical
pieces on stage it has different
configurations so so it can see many
hundreds of people hundreds of people in
the in the theater in theater
configuration and then also has of this
cafe this is this sort of part that uses
out which can serve as a pre-function
area all the things you'll learn about
when you start designing museums and
anyway so it's but I'll ikan victory
configurable and with screens on all
sides so it's a you know it uses the
concept of the doughnut of the of the
pavillon of the original museum as a way
to sort of reinforce the strength of
that that idea and not not to thwart it
necessarily so we're working with the
Fisher Dax and Jackie Holden a team that
we've worked with on many the theater
project so it's being treated as it as a
serious presentation space despite the
fact that it's only there for two months
of the year and it will have the ability
to change its acoustical properties
depending on what what things are are in
it okay it's it's um I should have said
that thank you it's it's actually pretty
that's pretty standard fiber-reinforced
what is that called it's the stuff that
you see it's actually translucent we're
taking liberties with with the skin
making it a bit more transparent but we
are putting sections of transparent
material within within the PDC PDC
basically and but it is it's foldable
and you can pack it up and it lasts for
many many years however the transparent
stuff has to be replaced over the years
because it's much more fragile but but
when it's not serving an event it can
actually just be an insulation I'm going
to show you a couple things about the
way it's made so in fact it's a little
more cloudy than this but it will change
the way that
circuit around the galleries works and
you really turn it into a special time
to be there sort of the bib indem
Michelin Man time and it leaves a space
you know leave space here so it's
constructing a lot of different
experience within the museum simply by
holding itself away from from the edge
of the building this is a sort of an
erection sequence there's a there's a
tension ring on the outside of this
thing actually weighs a lot so we have
to leave writing a new structure around
the the inside of the are the in the
inside edge of the museum to hold the
thing up so this the way this works is
it's unfurled in the plaza it's lifted
hoisted up with this new ring as the
structure and equipment that's up here
that keeps it inflated sort of out of
sight the the fabric is dropped down by
gravity and then it's inflated with this
equipment here and and that's what it is
pretty simple stuff so thank you
and the last person to present tonight
before we discuss the projects is Joe
Pesci amatsu when Liam was reading about
this Perino party there were many
episodes in the text that reminded me of
our life at oma back in the 90s where I
made a job so he showing OMA in 1998 and
became a partner in 2008 he has led the
OMA office in New York since 2006 he is
currently in charge of Cornell
University new buildings for the college
of architecture art and planning in
Ithaca shigematsu was a project leader
for the winning competition entry for
CCTV headquarters in Beijing has been a
driving force in conceptual projects
such as universal headquarters in Los
Angeles the Whitney Museum extension in
New York the Tokyo vertical campus the
China National Museum I'm Prada
epicenters fortune guy and London so he
is teaching a G sub D semester
hi we also have a to losing competitions
and recently it's made by dealer in
Scott video ranker it was a kind of
irony right this is a term that is
common use commonly used in Japan
scrapping built I I just wanna go read
diverse level temporarily I guess
compared to a very restrained previous
speakers so I show a lot of slides very
fast this is the buildings well let's
say Japanese cities are pretty much
defined by natural disasters these are
the kind of dwellings that are lost
through a lot of flooding typhoons and
Fire do you know there are some big
disasters such as this one and not to
mention the war itself which actually
you can see this is the center of Tokyo
that destroyed this much this was the
image and of course no wonder that all
the a movement that came after this war
had something to do with this completely
emptiness after the world and also the
general history of being destroyed by
natural disasters and now even this is
done by like architects in the same
generation as I am you can always see
some ephemeral ephemerality in in their
building this is ishigami s cube that
floats let's say maybe Cedric price was
one of the architects who defined
temporary structure as how programmatic
events individual interaction can define
basically architecture rather than the
other way around and you can see the fun
Palace which was supposed to run 24
hours with this programmatic box is
hanging from the ceiling and this was
that was done in sixties but
this is the expo 70s in 70 in Osaka
which had a programmatic roof as you
might know these boxes actually moved
around according to the events that
happened underneath and also Cedric was
the first one to maybe took the
inflatables as the most serious a
seriously basically these are the
proposal for the zoo and he even
proposed a system inflatable to clean
the seaside as Charles show these were
the inflatable done by Ram I was in
London pavilion you know all this but of
course the main purpose was to have a
hold an event which had a lot of events
that one of which was 24 hours marathon
interviews and of course when it's
illuminated pink it's always celebrity
events
this is a very important event for
fundraising for serpenton we also did a
tent for a European Union we designed a
flag for European Union as you might
know as opposed to blue and boring
monotonous flag we extracted the colors
of each members and then made a color
bar code and then that became our new
proposal for the flag and we made a
circus tent in the central roundabout in
Brussels which had a kind of ring
structure that has a ring of meeting
table and the ring of history of Europe
and history of European Union around
this was inside very busy as always some
attractions such as inside it was an
entire you Constitution bound into one
it was a kind of one long book how
cumbersome to become a new member and
also i became a perfect backdrop for all
the protests in brussels i moved to
austria we deploy what a flag was
deployed even more and for your former
president was used for prada we've done
series of different temporary events and
structure and a lot of diverse
interventions first of all we do a
fashion show two times per year alice is
one of the proposal that everyone gets
the first row since the fashion show
that the road determines the kind of
power this was a little bit more
three-dimensional version this was
almost like an arena where as
they're going to start like fighting but
it was a kind of fashion show I want to
also show a temporary store because the
pop-up stores became one of the typology
to kind of promote brands let's say
eagerness to infiltrate in the city this
was done by comme des Garcons in london
dover street market prada was inspired
by this and wanted to make the similar
store in Brompton close to Harrods in a
very awkward space was a former Porsche
garage next to the furniture store next
to a bar pub and also even though as you
can see the facade wealth was l-shaped
so this was inside was supposed to be
temporary and very low budget but the
interesting thing was that Prada owned
at the time a lot of different brands so
it was the first time that the Prada
wanted to show all the brands in one
store so we what we decided to combine
the department store typology which has
a one big floor one curated floor with
different brands and the Select shop
which has a different brand in a kind of
multi-story store first thing we did is
to make a so-called mask so we installed
a complete the similar regular product
store in the in the front so that
everyone get disguised but through the
back door you can go to the this
temporary store with shredded wall I
show you a couple of studies because I
think that's more interesting these were
the shapes that has different themes
that defines a residual space also this
was again using existing column grid
which was completely weird because it
was a hybrid
different spaces and we use the fabric
to define basically wrap all the
existing columns and create a different
space that creates a very awkward and
strange object this has we wanted to do
something completely different for the
store environment because we were a
little bit sick of let's say providing a
store that sells so we thought that we
could just insert the Boeing into this
space and use it as a backdrop for the
story of course it didn't go through
this is the other one we installed
series of different pedestals almost
like sea of them in a different size
different scale seemingly very random
but we started to program them by
orientation like this that all this
orientation has shelves or the other
orientation has a picture or art so that
seemingly random you can start to define
the program within the story but Indian
we showed well this was the chosen one
so we studied of course all the stores
and we discovered that a lot of stores
nowadays have a kind of overview so we
thought we articulate that articulated
that as overdose of overviews so we
wanted to make something more mysterious
this is a store so something that almost
looks like the fabric of London like
Lafayette Park that oma proposed in 80's
like a series of programmatic bands
which we thought it was interesting
because of the irregular shape of the
store people the customer don't know how
long this sequence continuous basically
so it's a series of just the kind of
installed walls
so when you enter you can go as long as
you want but you never know where to end
and the idea was to just install the
walls and do nothing else within the
score that evolved that was in London
that evolved to a store in Shanghai
became even more extreme this is him
this is burned this is kudo there's a
boardwalk here and underneath there are
a lot of Chinese local retails which we
wanted to insert the pop-up store so
there's a parking underneath the
boardwalk where we wanted to insert the
store and we wanted to keep certain
existing stores like this so basically
you have product stores next to all the
local details as you can imagine didn't
happen either we keep thinking this is a
exhibition design for brother skirts
hundreds skirts was a traveling
exhibition we design we were charged to
show the movement of the skirt while we
are not showing of course a model
wearing a skirt so what we came up with
is to show all these giant flat
mannequin we call to 2.5 times of the
actual size in your face and then have
them arrayed like this one sided mirror
so people are forced to walk in the
forest of legs like this this is actual
hung from the ceiling this is on the
mirror psychic kind of disappears in
certain angle
another another display which was
because it was traveling like a c2
studio we had to anticipate how it's
going to travel so we use this vacuum
setback method and vacuum factors skirt
which is true up typically the elevation
you you get to see the elevation but you
never get to see the plan so we chose
the sky skirts that are that has
interesting plans some skirt had a very
interesting like a thick fabric or the
three-dimensional cut that its standard
it by its own without any support like
this so we show them as a sculpture and
some skirt we use the ceiling fans to
rotate them and then see use this mirror
to see the backside or let's underside
which of course the team was all men so
it reflects that so this is
another one it's called pendulum so we
use the wiper motor of the car to
simulate so it has a battery here so it
has no electricity the trace of
electricity so people were of course
wondering how it is and the final
project that i want to show is the
so-called transformer i guess the whole
effort with prada somehow came together
in this project so proud i wanted to do
an event not only for fashion but also
for their art collection cinema
collection and fashion exhibition so
what we decided is to create a pavilion
that can transform for all four events
with one structure so we let's say al
Qaeda t like four different plants
optimized for each event and then made a
triangular pyramid like this and then
decide to rotate each time there is an
event well for each events this was a
structure for while we didn't really
know we knew exactly how we want it but
we didn't know how to clad it but we
discovered this material called cuckoo
was originally made for b-29 to protect
the b-29 how ironical is that they bomb
all the Japanese cities but anyway these
are the kind of the advertisement from
that time it's actually quite
interesting bridge ability elongation I
love these pictures
stretchability mil thickness so all this
kind of military
now it's also useful storages and for
still military purpose so we use that
membrane to cover the entire building
you basically sprays its place spray
them and then it stretches after that
with a chemical reaction and it creates
the most logical three dimensional curve
with its stretches to fit
so this is how we rotate it
and so this was the cinema configuration
this was the artist at installation and
at the end he was dismantled by local
art students in fashion students and
used as an event space in there the
first exhibition was that fashion
exhibition that we did the idea was that
since this was the first event we in the
transformer and we wanted to imply that
what you see on the wall will be become
a floor in the future so we use those
mannequins that which I showed you
earlier to walk on the different surface
like this in the end and the most
beautiful moment in this pavilion came
when they install this so I just want to
show you so this was a scaffolding just
to put those mannequins onto the
different surface it's like a pier neezy
and then all these guys moving one by
one month fixing
and from outside at night you can see
all the scaffolding
thank you
looks like eight o'clock so i have many
questions but should we start with a
question from them to us yes sorry I'm
is a mature person we were always p yes
so if there is something like in the
music that you have a notation of
writing or just section and drawing so
how are you representing and events
between people short do you want to do
you understand the question yeah sorry I
didn't understand can you I'll say
Photoshop
I mean that drawer is really growing and
photoshop II yeah and and so you do
several to represent in time or just a
Photoshop to give the feeling and that's
it I think the representation is like a
planning of the event itself to come up
with the event is the basically what
you're talking about I guess after
planning there's certain rules how to
achieve that or how to simulate them so
I also feel like in the case of a
European pavilion that you did it's more
about coming up with the elements the
objects you would say because you're
Nora sculptures they're not architecture
there certain objects that will spur a
type of reaction and the way people the
events that happen I'm not new but the
way the objects present themselves to
the people and a thinking process
stationary it's what it's supposed to be
what is no no it's not like people are
going to walk differently it's not it's
not like we have to come up with
notations for choreographing or anything
like that it's more about the assemblage
of a narrative in the in terms of
objects that are part of a narrative I
would say and I think the if I can if I
may elevate the discussion to something
similar but I think there is a certain
aesthetics and longing of the architects
to dream of such a spate like a
temporary space where you're no longer
have any code as you were saying nor any
sprinklers and I think it was also very
clear that juxtaposition of the
temporality and permanence in Charles's
project and I think that's something
that all the temporary structure always
has this kind of strange feeling
all those open-endedness i guess but i
have a question which is may be directed
at you which is that I think to a
certain extent all of us are aware that
pavilions in the 20th century what I've
been starting to think of as a almost
sort of positive deception meaning that
works we accept that we can suspend our
doubt and disbelief in the Belgian
political system or the operations of
Philips as a as a multinational company
and its involvement whatever it may have
done in and whatever technology is it
may have contributed to and the same
with the function of the pavilion is
there as a space to pop up and make a
gentrifying area or appear attractive
and all these other things so the
question is really about the the
architects responsibility in terms of
the the ethics of deploying a pavilion
you know what kind of discussions do you
guys get into when you're working for
these festivals and art fest there's a
big difference between a community
festival in an art fair for example
they're completely different beasts but
by deploying the the pavilion in both
sites it seems to imply that there is a
is a kind of equivalents of Advent pneus
that can't be distinguished you know
that there's no discrimination between
the two types of thing well some extent
it's it's just like the movement of
people within that event is something
that we're kind of exploring that I mean
there's issues related to to the
specific events themselves but at some
level we're really just trying to see
how can we affect the way people would
interact with this structure you know if
they're at it at this big concert venue
like the all points west it's just like
Matt
the three day long thing which is like
you know it's like millions of dollars
going to this one event where since the
other community event which is very tiny
but it's just got like a whole different
audience that we have to try to see what
how we can interact with them mm-hmm but
do you recognize this idea that there is
some strange lure about this idea of the
the building that is not a building
where has this temporary quality that is
very appealing but also extremely
complicated because it's the moment when
when you have this sort of paradox in a
way that we assume that to a certain
extent the architect or architects are
doing what they want to do like this
isn't an expression of their
uncompromised desires but on the same at
the same time it also has to represent
unresolvable differences in a strange
way it's got this weird paradox it seems
that oh my get around it by like with
the European thing that you're you do it
by literally showing off the very things
that the problem like the great big
Constitution which is an amazing thing
but I don't know well in this text by
Andrea Andrea Phillips says that you
know they are the pavilions that used to
be an architecture that you walk in and
so it was about the space and then the
pavilions came more and more like
objects like sculptures and so it
shifted from architecture to sculpture
and she there in one way sees the
pavilion becoming an specimen in itself
so that there would be no architects or
sculptures doing or artists doing
pavilions the way pavilion ists doing
pavilions like a new discipline which I
find very uncomfortable to think that
you become like you know an entire new
set of expertise devoted to to that um I
but for this aunty days today we saw
like a degree
like the pavilion as a temporary
building by where the war building
really carries it its way it's a
building and the pavilion as a manifesto
that I would say the European pavilion
it's a kind of money it's a manifesto to
open book in a way and the pavilion has
a kind of a kit of parts or it is sort
of fascinating the her Sean thinkers in
a way it's incredibly disruptive I mean
it said if you look at it intersect was
that make sense incredibly disruptive
could you talk a little bit about that
the differences in in the way these
things get judged if you see what I mean
we have the the jokey exchanges about
competition some some will even artists
are aware of this this kind of procedure
but you did mention once maybe you could
talk about it a bit more this idea that
certain things they're easier because
it's inflatable or it's a pavilion then
it's not a building well I just want to
talk a little bit about your your
comment about the Delirium of pavilion
making which is sort of what you're
alluding to which is sort of it's beyond
it doesn't have to play by the rules in
it it's sort of like the spectacle the
idea of spectacle and the Delirium of of
the undoable which is I think really
optimistic it's really interesting that
it's all it's about the future somehow
and so it seems to be about anticipating
what could be right I mean and and maybe
the thought is that it's it's leading to
some form of thought or degree of
thought which is more permanent in
nature I don't know if it's if it's a
stepping stone towards of some sort of
permanence or some sort of you know
can-can our buildings start to actually
be built to transform should they I mean
I don't know or is that Dustin to simply
be you know
a one-off kind of thing I mean it's
really exciting but are there lessons to
be learned that could anticipate the
future and I mean I guess I lost track
of your initial question but I sort of
wanted to tie it was quite a technical
one it was literally about I mean that
it's perfectly I it was very interesting
the way you took it but it was literally
about the pavilions also hypnotize the
client in a way in the same way that I'm
prepared to accept no I haven't don't
get me wrong I don't have any problem
with prana or any of these things but if
I'm I suddenly even I like Prada much
better than I thought I did earlier
today I found I think they're amazing
and I'm real label you know I you know
but better sort of mean there is
something but is there a moment where of
course we all know that this is a
logical thing that that people think
this is not going to be forever and
therefore it it doesn't matter but of
course as a brand guess this thing might
be the only thing that gets in the
newspapers the only thing that becomes
visible it is the pin the only news I've
heard about the herschel in the last
night yes I think it's a little bit too
much to say as as if the aqua architects
are interested in temporary structure as
their ultimate kind of utopian
expression because there are a lot of
architects will actually create
temporary structure for post natural
disasters or just a kind of local
festivity event I mean it's just a kind
of selection of people today just maybe
gives you some kind of wrong idea and
I'm happy that someone like you is
actually teaching the studio because it
avoids to become this kind of pavilion
like pavilion that that always been a
kind of entrance of all the Ivy League
schools you know like this kind of put
together like parts whatever and also in
even in our cases I think that it's not
just temporary structure in our case
which we project soon
hypnotized to the client it's also a
permanent structure we are charged to in
a way to give certain satisfaction that
they have as a kind of you know I iconic
structure so I think it's a bit
difficult to insert the kind of almost
like an ethical level but is certainly
don't make it seem like there's much
official barrier as I you know it's more
to get you to define these these things
in a more in a more precise way because
I think it certainly has come up sorry
I'm a bit watching too much TV but it
does lead to this other question which
it's really clear in the art context
that in the last since 1978 there's been
just to think of a date there's been a
clear developing difference between what
museums and institutions collect for
example and what they show in order to
generate a kind of cultural capital to
prove that they're doing something new
and progressive and interesting and is
that maybe someone could talk to this
idea of whether or not the how we deal
with this issue that the one thing that
this Columbia project might have in
common with you know Europe or Prada or
what have you or trying to come up with
a new type of structure is that in a way
can let people of the hook that the more
you allow more you deal with temporary
mess in this way that's kind of
interesting inherently interesting
there's no obligation to actually do
anything interesting in a concrete level
is there something to talk about well no
I wondered if you are getting to a
critique of architecture by you know in
that question right i mean your same
architecture but just it's about if an
artist accepts to do like temporary
projects as a museum but at the same
time the museum will only buy other
types of work that they're real
investment is in something else these
things are also do cheap if we do
something interesting colombia looks
great right it look really sexy for
very little money but sexier than the
reality if maybe the the real planned
built to be built infrastructure is I
think one of the things though is is
about shared space and when when a
museum commissions like Doug akin to
take over a whole block of the city of
New York that that's a really democratic
really interesting way to think about
using that space in many different ways
over the course of time gives it gives
the artist a bigger a bigger voice and
platform and so I there's a little yeah
I don't know I think it's a slightly the
wrong way to look it to frame the
question maybe or something I think all
of all of these my building to my other
thing to do is a similar kind of deal in
the great weather it goes away and
you're outside and so no but I think a
lot of you know when I first came aware
of Cedric prices work which was
introduced to me by architects not by
any art people you know it seemed to be
something that could be that could be
cultural architecture meaning the
architecture of cultural institutions
and yet it seems that there's a certain
degree of conservatism about the way
museum construction has been going with
a few exceptions yet yet the Pavilion is
always deployed in a way to somehow make
everything seem ok somehow why wash I
think one of the issues is said the
bigger the building them or the bigger
the object being art or architecture the
more consensus you need around it and so
I think that when we look at a pavilion
when you look when you look at an
individual our piece you maybe need the
consensus of the artist and the person
buying it hanging it talking about it
and so you're talking about the
consensus of one to three people and
they larger you know in the dog Aiken
that I think it's a very good example in
order to expose that in the sea
you have new york you need the consensus
of hundreds of people and I think in
architecture the pavilion is probably
the smallest we can go and the kind of
the smallest consensus we can get and so
if we were proposing a bill a new
building on campus either for a disaster
relief or for a you know to build the
sweatshirts of the University we will
need whatever the purpose we would need
the consensus of so many people and for
the pavilion we need a laser concern so
therefore there's a more a larger degree
of freedom and so regardless of who the
sponsor or the backers are the in
architecture we look for opportunities
to minimize the amount of people we have
to convince productive I'm lipid
surprise you as an artist who of course
know the kind of system of how to get
funding and I mean it's not a joke that
I showed that body in serpentine it's
really used to get money for the salt so
to certain agree you need attention we
need to cry for the attention but what
is maybe different is that architecture
architects as I showed most of the
projects are still having clients it's
not like our desire that you know it's
not a spontaneous project which may be
in your case here is slightly be a
spontaneous project I think that
difference as a kind of ultimate outcome
is an interesting one to see what what
the difference is and I'm really looking
for do you think that's what extent do
you think we shouldn't in this kind of
semi we've got a semi client in a way we
do sort of have one the one that's
somewhat indulgent and technically on
our side but to what extent should we
one thing that's really key about what
you seem to do is he both inform the
client
about things they don't know about and
also play with them it seems really
clear you kind of feel it's a bit like
Philippe's but you're kind of screwing
with them a little bit in a productive
way but is that for you a central part
of the process right if the client is
kind of weak do you have to prop them
into life in a way do you have to wake
them up I don't know what defines a week
client be tolerant tolerant and whatever
you want for example for or just silent
and and cope you know bureaucratic for
example right well it's true that
nowadays people who want to use the
pavilion as a communication strategy
marketing strategy they are all powerful
that's no doubt I mean now Guggenheim is
doing this mobile mobile thing everyone
is jumping onto it's just a kind of part
of their campaign communication so yes
the in certain degree like we have to
ride on the wave and then come up with
something that is artistic which
sometimes be you know playing with them
and sometimes being really true to the
need of the event inside what the one
thing I would say about our thing what
the first one is the building the
hirshhorn self is incredibly iconic and
in credit it was incredibly significant
as a building to begin with and in
remains you know one of the most
emblematic buildings in Washington and I
think what we were trying to do was
actually meet the aspirations of that
building with a new taio new form of a
new generation and you know the event as
a as a fundraising tool which again it's
that's one of the primary things it's
there for it's expressing its expressing
our current economic and social
condition but it's trying to do it
formally in a way that's you know
equivalent to the to the original I me
not equivalent but you know in a similar
aspirational nature
you think from the Civic time Cilic
price times to now there has been an
increase in the relevance of the city
and the appeal of the bells you know you
imagine like in the 70s there was late
please people living in New York or
London that they are now and the events
were of a different nature and so I
think many of these pavilions are about
fulfilling that kind of I would say more
primal desire to meet and greet in there
in the summer that's why I think the be
at risk alumina quote of of a butterfly
or you know both words and our weddings
and butterflies happen to happen in
mostly in spring and summer and I think
it has to do well in the summer it's
when we want to expand expand our
horizons meet more you know either go to
New Territories or just you know go out
but I was thinking about all the way
you're done in the shop and working on
the temporary structures that if you
look at it from from from from many
perspectives and you look at artists
like to be as poetry or some works of
Allah for Elias and some projects of
peer week and other artists in the last
year's even andreas Attell although
formerly it has a very different
appearance there's very little I can't
work out much difference between what
you're doing and they're doing is artist
so what are your thoughts on this when
how what level you know where does this
the the presentation of your work sit in
the culture is it ok if it's misread if
it can it be misread when people deal
with it as a an equivalent form to
contempt certain aspects of contemporary
sculpture how do you negotiate that or
deal with it I don't know that I mean
does the temporariness mean that it's
does lend itself to being Israeli any
more than I mean it could it can be a
positive miss reading I mean it's purely
a question about differentiation of
being able to tell there's very little
difference in the way you've been
working in certain artists have been
working which means there's been a cross
fertilization whether or not both sides
are always aware of it it goes in both
directions there are many architects who
are basically talking artists through
processes and vice versa but it does
seem to have a particular particular
resonance when you get this supposedly
natural combination of an arts art
school department and an architecture
department that there seem to be these
basic issues of like I don't know the
Dane danger of were on a dangerous level
you produce a sort of hermaphrodite but
I was thinking maybe that's the wrong
that maybe sounds negative my much
shoham Aphrodite so negative but I kind
of a lack of ability to recognize what
type of thing you are dealing with is
that important see I I don't think so I
mean right I think it's so you're you're
engaging in in some part of the city in
some kind of interaction with the public
how it's red is you know it's not for us
to say it's not right necessarily for
you know architecture artists to say
either I mean it's really I feel like
with with these kind of temporary things
you can happen perhaps more of an effect
or you know a different kind of effect
benefit was like a permanent
installation in place but either way I
mean there's certain relations that
others are going to read and determine
what what
we doing to a culture but it's good to
know from you that you have such a
reading we're going to be careful that
are set out by yes the client the
villainous client or the wonderful
client and in the case of I'll say as
the administrator in the architecture
school who's putting through the
pavilion thing we searched for a client
this is not glorifying Columbia
University maybe we'll we hope hope not
I don't know depends on the students
event but in in the way of thinking of
like architects we actually had we were
desperate to find this client because
the client is what makes the rules and
the architecture needs the rules as much
as you want to say it doesn't it doesn't
want it wants to do what it wants to do
it doesn't know what to do when it
doesn't have rules and so when we met
finally the facilities manager of
Columbia University who said oh this has
to be up during commencement and has all
these rules it was like wow great like
it has to respond and and and so the
university actually didn't then it's
funny the event thing because this money
that we got from Provost's never was
intended for a pavilion it was intended
to produce events events much like this
and we actually found that not very
ambitious just inviting anish kapoor to
talk about art and architecture or doug
aitken for that matter didn't really
respond enough to the kind of
collaboration we wanted so we've we've
created this monster right we've created
this pavilion idea we've gone and found
a client in the university and we're
kind of dragging everyone through it so
so I just wanted to say also that I
would love before we wrap this up to get
two more questions from the students who
might be working on this type of stuff
maybe this is a naive question but if if
temporary and permanent are not
opposites but rather two points along
one timeline then if is the power the
transformative power of the pavilion
that it transforms whatever object you
put in it or whoever passes through it
due in part to the fact that Eden of
itself is transformative erected
deconstructed rapidly and if so at what
point to something temporary become
permanent because when you showed the
scaffolding through the cloth or when
you said the wood the wood kept getting
heavier as we added it I don't I don't
know where that line is and clearly it's
blurry but maybe you have a better sense
of it I just want to quickly say the
obvious which is of course as a
foreigner every time for the last 20
years whenever I've arrived back here
I've gone past the what appeared to be
some temporary pavilions and queens that
I couldn't work out if they were what
they appeared to be and I think for my
side of it the the biggest danger of
this pavilion is that it doesn't go away
to see what I mean that the that the
taunting presence of the pavilion that
was intended only temporarily that the
world is littered with temporary
projects that were preserved us or last
it Mike I do think yes me my thumb
disappeared because is fascinating I
just want to say that every I mean this
is so obvious but everything is
temporary I mean you know when I get a
brief on of her on a museum project
which I have gotten this they'll tell
you it needs its 24 25 year life span
which time it may get torn down it make
it added on to so I mean I get it's just
it's an academic way to look at it but I
think that you can't draw those
distinctions so precisely look at that
amazing presentation as the the graphics
of the you know take it tear it down and
build again
attitude is it does that mean that we
should be looking obviously this makes
perfect sense but beyond just looking at
pavilions it would seem to imply a
certain methodology about looking at
time in relation to construction and so
on to looking outside maybe go on a road
trip rather than staying here I mean
there are a lot of buildings that were
meant to be temporary in like expose but
became permanent I mean so those are
interesting example for you to look at
and what I wanted to say by showing the
Japanese case is that the scale of
temper ality also differs in different
culture so in Japan like you feat last
like more than 50 years that's almost
permanent nowadays it used to be
different but I think it's a great
privilege to be in control of your
demise of your own buildings you know I
say it's it's terrifying when you see
them the K so it's good give you thank
you for a really stimulating
presentation I'm not an architect but
what I noticed in that all of your
presentations had in common was that
they stressed the beauty of the
installation process and the
performativity of the installation
process and also in some cases of the
deconstruction I was thinking about the
herschel and thinking what I really want
to see is the bubble being inflated and
I wondered how much those of you who
regularly build these structures plan
for the aesthetics of the creation in
public and and then the deconstruction
as well whether that's something that
you really think about aesthetically and
if so whether that's really a defining
feature of temporary structures I could
say for for the projects I showed I mean
that was kind of the the project it's
like we were designing that event and
you know during that process we were
sort of guiding where it would go but
I'm
the whole form was resolved during that
that event which you know you could then
carry it through the entire like
delivery the Assembly of it and then
through the life of the festival which
is also this short term event so it's
kind of yeah I mean that whole period of
time it was really the purpose in the
case of those three pavilions I also
think the in the in situ case there is
it you you created a way of addicting
the place that it's kind of anxiety free
in a way is because it's not a in
architecture you usually have a
prescriptive form it needs to look this
way at the end and in your case you
created a process therefore it doesn't
really matter so much how exactly goes
together as long as kind of it goes
through a series of rules in a different
case it's different but one thing I want
to say that after 911 I think even in a
permanent structure people started to
imagine how it could collapse I think
that was the whole I not I open and that
sounds positive but you know very
uncommon to see such an event and to
realize how building can be so
vulnerable and collapse yeah i'm
wondering if or your thoughts if you
think that architecture is the or
pavilions are the most appropriate mode
for architecture in this age which is
dominated by a temper ality and
extremely fast pace of living and that
perhaps the pavilion in our age is the
most appropriate means of having social
effect yeah i think so i think that
pavilions will beat there will be more
and more and they will respond to this
idea of gathering
in some in the summertime you know for
different issues and whether it's
protest or commerce there will be the
whole gamut of reasons you got to
remember that the text i was reading
which was from 15 years ago is itself
also part of the critique of event
culture or participation that i think at
the very least during this process and i
think it's our obligation as a
university to come up with some critical
sensibility at least if not something
concrete about the you know in around
these questions I wanted to say I'm
thinking about this all night this in
itself as an event you mentioned that
and one of the thing one of the things
that I think mark and you guys have done
up here at Columbia is turn the school
into only events no I'm done being very
harsh but but there are so many more
events here than there were when I was
here when events were really significant
and really special now I you know I'm up
here seven times this semester I mean
okay no that's really exciting no but
the point is in its I'm not acting it's
not a criticism I think it's really a
bit sup I'm just saying that the world
has changed into and it's all
event-driven I mean you think about a
tweet it you know that's not you know
that's not a handwritten let its a tweet
you know like and everything is about
event and so whether or not it's you
know temp you know pavilions are the
appropriate response it they're
certainly reflective of a culture but
but honestly I mean you can't how is
people that easily in them and they
aren't going to satisfy but the bulk of
what we need shelter to do ever know
because the event-driven I don't think
it bounds architecture to temporary
structure and I mean that's what you're
saying yeah
I'm sorry I didn't mean to be critiquing
too but I just think it's am observing
but can I just spin it a little bit that
you know I think that that of course as
you know there are there's events and
events and you know I'm um I'm aware
that we're dear can i have a semi yeah
I'll have a penultimate work and then
yeah but I just want to be a bit
romantic for a minute and and to try and
also break down a a kind of false
moralism about types of event and years
ago I was at doing something in this to
the end someone invites me to go to a
communist festival and I idea what I
communist festival is I know the
communist is right and what's a
communist festival and I was driven out
into the countryside near Pisa to the
middle of nowhere what felt like the
middle of nowhere and confronted by a
series of ad hoc structures some of
which had been clearly designed some of
which had been clearly just thrown
together and in that place in that kind
of terrain of improvised structures you
had both on one hand like the biggest
most blown out eurotrash techno party
I've ever been to in my life and a place
to discuss Graham Chi and the idea of
again ax me within political culture
just alongside and I'm not advocating
that we could achieve anything like that
but we do at least have something in
common with that sort of structure in
the sense that it's a bounding bounding
idea bounding identification but within
it contains these potential extreme so
yeah that's all I can say about that
that's my penultimate work haven't you
oh I have I have no final word I I do
believe that we started a process
of making and I I believe that every
student that is in the studio every day
of the studio every meeting realizes the
amount of consensus building that it
takes to do anything and I think when
you give you a nine and then and we
started this conversation together the
four of us the issue was what can we do
with this money that will be educational
in a way that it that it talk is not so
we talked about you know you can have
this amount of money and invite for
people and so what is the event value or
the educational value of having shipped
coons a talk here and you know and rim
and so we decided show can talk to
students they had you know they can see
revving youtube any day so so it's it's
about the process as much as it is about
the final product of the Pavilion will
be and I hope to see you under the
pavilion in May thank you
we know